that doctor like Bell was instrumental
in making sure that this ceremony
occurred I served in the US Army Medical
Corps as a major in the US Army Medical
Corps during the Vietnam conflict I had
very little interest in the history of
the military I the United States or
otherwise but after I left the army I
developed an interest in the history
primarily of military history of the
United States we have an outstanding
World War one monument just out the
window of my office and the Naomi Berrie
Diabetes Center and for the past 20
years while I have been in this office I
have watched that Monument and the park
which is adjacent to it the John
Mitchell Park and have been fascinated
to look at some of the names on the
World War 1 veterans monument my own
engagement with this monument has come
through efforts to replace and repair
the bayonet which has been removed under
serial circumstances during my presence
here and the most recent which began in
2016 has actually involved my offering
and the offer being accepted by the
parks department to help to pay for the
restoration in order to expedite that
process and to get the repairs made
before the hundredth anniversary of the
ending of the war I think the fact that
this is being used as an opportunity for
the congressman and for other members of
the community to pay renewed attention
hopefully to this wonderful piece of art
and historical importance of its
representation of a very important
period in world and American history I
think this is a priceless opportunity in
a sense and there's another point
actually which is of historical interest
to me the discovery of insulin was made
by a world
one veteran of the Canadian military
forces that participated in France
during the war so we're almost a hundred
years away from a discovery made by a
member of the Armed Forces who fought
and actually was decorated for his
courage in the First World War